well hello you guys look amazing thank
you thank you sure there's something
there's a chemistry that I'm seeing do
you know what it is made to the outfits
mama told me she was gonna wear green so
I put on my green jacket I think that's
what it was it attacks this morning to
decide I don't know in advance Oh at
least three days yeah I'm wearing green
mmm oh you guys I don't know probably a
black t-shirt I didn't lie but then I
throw in this green jacket I like that
that's ten honor of the silkie of the
sookie sookie sookie sookie sings so
good thing on so the punisher season two
I'm excited about it but personally for
me what I'm looking most forward to is
you getting revenge on him will we see
that in season two your character when
we first see Dina this season yes she's
obviously hugely scarred from what Billy
has done to her last season and what a
lot of the other characters have moved
on yeah that's what Dina's fixated on
yeah so a big part of her this season is
getting that revenge and whatever way
possible and in the first season you
know she was kind of deliberating over
whether she should go the correct ways
to do that yeah and I think there this
season she realizes you know he's going
down he's going down
so yeah you'll see that yeah Marvel fans
are such huge fans just in the release
of the trailer alone people are picking
apart frame by frame we're either of you
anticipating the reaction that you got
just took like jigsaws face people were
saying you know he should have more
scars but it could have been a clip from
any part in the season so what is your
reaction to stuff like that I mean I
anticipated it from a makeup test before
we even started shooting this season and
I was like pitching to do it have it be
more gruesome hmm and I was anticipating
this moment and I knew it was coming but
actually what I think that we settled on
was something which is much more
cerebral and interesting which is about
the jigsaw being
in Billy Russo's mind having to find
those pieces those fractured pieces and
put put his life back together and put
his mission back together and put
himself back together and I think we you
know also with everything in the show we
want to ground it in something you know
historically military and I think that
you know there's sort of four these
really interesting ways that the
veterans deal with their brain injuries
and how they see themselves and you you
know unless you come back missing a limb
maybe people don't really see the the
injuries that are on the inside and
Billy we treated him like like it like a
like a veteran and like a hero us but
someone who's really suffering and so
it's about how he sees himself in the
mirror rather than about how other
people react to his to his gruesome face
and and so we were trying to trying to
investigate something a little bit more
subtle with him you know in an attempt
to make this season really kind of
different and fresh and what people
might expect but I think there's enough
you know Punisher kicking people in the
face to to satisfy those you know
hardcore Porsche fans but I you know I
kind of knew that moments coming but
hopefully by the time they get to the
end of episode 13 they'll go
I'd seed you know what I like what they
do with that I mean I'm hoping yeah well
your face in real life looks great given
what happened in season one but if you
were to have a mask in real life what
kind of design would you put on it would
there be kittens rainbows
I reckon kidding right what would you
play I do like I do like a kitten
anything finally put on it I guess it
would be kinda like a tattoo
almost yeah exactly it would be it would
be like a tattoo I'm so indecisive I've
never got tattoo only for the reason
that I that I can't
I could I could never land on one
specific thing that I would then be
committed to but you know that I I
posted a couple articles actually about
about you know these these art therapy
moths and that's just fascinating is to
be like I want to be seen this way
before I'm able to open up to you I need
you to see me like like I see myself and
that is like a really interesting thing
about to make people think about how you
see
yourself in life I think it's like a
really interesting thing I know this
isn't more cerebral answer than you were
then you I hope there's more but yes and
of course bands are always creating
rumors but there's a rumor that this
could be the final season of The
Punisher so will season to end off with
it kind of closing us or will it kind of
leave us open to season 3 I think I mean
I think with the show what's interesting
is that there's never like definite
right wrong open closed yes no yes so it
leaves I mean it leaves things we hope
the audience will be satisfied with with
what we've created
but it's a show with a lot of gray areas
anyway yeah and I think in life you know
we don't have an open clothes of
everything
things aren't perfectly wrapped up so
when you're when you're showing
something on screen you try to emulate
that but I will say it will feel like
the end of a season that you know it
will feel like the universe even there's
definite punch okay yeah okay well thank
you so much thanks for your answer
excited
you